[Music]
[Applause]
luna the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to the leia
hile puns show i have a very exciting
guest today
malcolm how you doing i'm great how are
you leia
i'm good thank you before we jump in um
this is
powered by um icon plus capital they're
a vc firm very cool
and it's also sponsored by block fire
you can get up to 250
i think when you sign up um interest
rates are great which i think we need
right now so go check them out
malcolm thanks for joining me where
abouts you right now
i am um in in new york
uh and i am about to head to
the epicenter of the bitcoin show
this week um i'm about to head to miami
and it's so funny leia i haven't been to
an event
like this in 18 months
i don't know how to act around large
groups of people
so i wonder if i'm just gonna walk into
big groups of people
and just be so weird i mean that was
already the case but i feel like it's
gonna be amplified so
we'll see no i think everybody i think
everybody's feeling the same way it's
like the first conference in so long
um and i think people have been on
lockdown for
for ages depending on which country
you're flying in from which state you're
flying in from
and people just have some kind of like
weird stockholm
syndrome where they kind of don't want
to go out but they have to go out now
i think it's going to be strange i'm
with you well
i think it's going to be um a really
interesting week
i mean what's interesting is around this
time of year we would typically have the
consensus conference hosted by coindesk
in new york
and i remember that was always such a
major event and would always coincide
with a major
market rally we called it the consensus
pump so be interesting to see right now
on the fear versus greed index we're in
the extreme fear sort of range
and so it'll be interesting to see if
people getting together with all of
their favorite bitcoiners
um and talking about bitcoin will sort
of help alleviate some of the fears but
the bears are out in full force right
now and i
don't understand okay so i i was gonna
ask you this a little bit later but
since you brought it up let's just go
for it now
what are your thoughts on the current
market is this the end
of the bull cycle or a we or is this or
or is it we sort of are we sort of just
finding out you know market value
and things are calming down are we sort
of heading head first now into a bear
market
yeah so so that's a great question and
and one that i think everyone's asking
themselves right now
um i don't have a crystal ball if i did
i'd be really rich
but i don't um the the only thing
i would say i mean there's sort of three
three things we need to look at
so first of all bitcoin doesn't exist in
isolation right
so if we look at the broader macro
context right now
there's a lot of fear in regular
equities markets and other markets
as well obviously since the start of
kovitz markets have sort of been in
in disarray last year we saw the
decoupling of core equities versus tech
right value versus growth with value
lagging
since core equities were hit really hard
by the pandemic and reduced demand
um tech saw massive growth right in some
of the valuations in the tech sector i
mean
if you remember when zuma ipo'd for a
long time
rating at a 1500 x forward eps
multiple right so that's like or sorry
1500 x forward pe multiple so 1500x
price to earnings multiple
meaning the stock was valued at 1500
times
their actual uh expected fiscal year
earnings
so that you know i think is a clear
example of um
some separation from from reality there
uh tesla similarly
uh you know nikola which is an electric
car company that's never produced a
single electric car was valued at over
i think 60 billion dollars at one point
i mean
the right it's sort of preposterous over
the last
three months what we've seen is the
economy starts to reopen
as our world starts to reopen um i think
there's still a lot of fear
institutions have pulled back capital
there's now over three trillion dollars
of dry powder on the sidelines
at its peak in may of 2020 was about
three trillion
3.2 trillion so we're getting close to
record highs of dry powder
unallocated cash on the sidelines and to
me
the real question is where is that
capital going to flow once allocators
start allocating again
what's interesting though is there's a
divergence between institutions and
between retail
so let me just highlight what this means
in macro markets and how that applies to
crypto
because it's really interesting right
like my my job and what we do at coin
share is we look at data
data tells us about sentiment sentiment
informs demand
and demand informs where the market
heads right
it's not always a clear-cut sort of
interpretation
but using data to inform your
perspective i think is one of the
the core skills you can you can have of
course um
so if we look at the macro side right i
just explained to you that institutions
have been really really bearish right
they're pulling back cash they're
uncertain about what's going to happen
to rates
they're uncertain about tax implications
so they've pulled back cash and they're
waiting to deploy
so institutions are taking risk off of
the table in the broader equities market
um retail not the case right
retail is on the extreme greed part of
the spectrum
retail is risk on and we see this with
retail being
allocated to amc gamestop and a number
of really high risk speculative stocks
but we see it across the spectrum retail
has been deploying capital has been very
actively investing and taking on more
risk
retail also is participating in the
market
far more than they ever have at any
point in marketing
which is really important so let's go
over to crypto right so there's this
backdrop where like
the big money is scared and they're like
oh we don't know what we're gonna do
they're waiting
right they're waiting for the other shoe
to drop but retail is like hey
let's go like we're in a pandemic i
haven't been working
everyone's getting rich i'm not nothing
to lose yeah it right
all in chips all in okay so how does
this tie to crypto
we're seeing the exact same thing in
crypto
may 19 was the single
busiest spot trading day in the history
of the crypto
ecosystem if we look at activity
right on the institutional quote-unquote
platforms which tend to be us dollar
denominated some coinbase gemini
etc activity right has been
way down um in terms of participation on
the bitcoin side over the last
five months if we look at the non-us
exchanges the crypto to crypto venues
where a wider range of assets are
offered right where people go to trade
the long tail of coins
yeah the record levels of participation
record levels of inflows and outflows on
binance
um throughout the end of may right
retailers participating whether they're
buying or they're selling they're in
they're trading this market they're
really active
the other thing i'll note is that coin
shares we track weekly fund flows so all
of the money
moving into and out of crypto related
etps funds publicly listed
products our biggest well 40 of our
business roughly is our asset management
business we've
passive crypto etps in the market we've
done that since 2015
and we have about five billion in assets
under management there so we track
inflows and outflows on a weekly basis
um i can flip you the link but it's on
our blog we publish it every week it's a
great resource
over the last three weeks for the first
time since we started that report and
honestly for the first time since we
started
um our business right we saw net
outflows
so historically we've had a pattern of
net inflows or no activity obviously
12 months with way more funds and etfs
in different markets launching
we now have a lot more data to look at
used to be just our own data but
now there's you know wider way wider
range of market participants
but what we saw is in the middle of may
first week of outflows 50 million of net
outflows from bitcoin etps
last week over 100 million of outflows
in this this
sorry two weeks ago 100 million and this
last week um
another week in that outflows it was in
early may it was just
outflows from bitcoin products there
were still inflows into ethereum
products and other
etp products this past week we saw in
outflows across all product lines so
again if we look at the data
right people are taking their money out
of the market people are putting money
on the sidelines and then i'll add one
last data point that's really important
the amount of usdc and usdt
and stablecoin last week on wednesday
for the first time
crossed the 100 billion dollar mark
right i think over the last five days
alone we've printed close to three
billion dollars worth of usdc
which is roughly i think 20 percent
close to 20 of the overall market cap of
usdc
so what we're seeing in the crypto space
as well is that similar behavior that i
described on the macro side
where people are going risk off people
are feeling skittish
they're taking money off the table and
they're waiting to figure out where the
bottom is before they redeploy
but i don't think we're in a bear market
or about to enter bear market
and here's why sentiment is more bullish
than
ever if you listen to what's happening
in the media if you look at the
institutions that are participating if
you look at the products that are coming
to market
if you look at the way people are
initiating coverage on crypto equities
if you look at the way that people are
initiating sell side and buy side
research coverage
on the crypto asset class as a whole
right goldman sachs is writing reports
about d5
like again that that's not bear market
things
i think what we have is a correction
bitcoin since the start of the year
started at 20 year trebled to 65k has
settled
at around 35 we're still up a lot
right ether started the year at around a
thousand
um trebled ran all the way to 4 500 now
is resting at around 2500
i think where we are is a pullback we
tend to see pullbacks and consolidation
when the market gets overheated
and honestly like we can't have up only
i know that we want to hit up only
but um these markets are volatile and i
think this is a correction
i think we need to wait to see macros
sort of stabilize and people get a sense
of direction in a heading
but people are sitting on the sidelines
with cash long-term holders are buying
these dips
i know you know i've been excited that
bitcoin's on sale
not investment advice but some of us are
excited about the dips um
and what we see right now is fear and
pain but i'm convinced that a crypto
summer is coming
yeah i think um i think right now such
an interesting time because
like you said okay so we've had this you
know 50 pullback it looks like a bear
market but
you're right sentiment is crazy right
now um you know with with um
the senator the senator of wyoming
goldman sachs like you said
um just so much so much is happening um
but i want to go back just a little bit
because i've watched a lot of your stuff
follow a lot of your stuff and i think
you speak so eloquently
um on the topic thank you so much oh
it's my pleasure no it's my pleasure but
honestly um you know i i see you all
over
um like the american news and and
everything so
how did you how did you get into crypto
like where did your um grounding stocks
i know that you
were was it oil and gas and things like
that before so
where did you accumulate so much
knowledge
that's a good question i don't
know um you know it's you know it's
really funny like
people have different things they care
about right like some people
care about money um some people care
about fame some people care about
power i'm driven by knowledge and i
always have been which is so
weird like uh when i was a kid actually
my dad will appreciate this story when i
was a kid i grew up in in the
netherlands right do you remember
encyclopedia britannica leia no
okay what is that and so what is that
okay this is so
i'm such a loser it's hilarious okay so
encyclopedia britannica um when i was
growing up in the 90
like early 90s right was um
basically this so there was no wikipedia
right like the internet really wasn't a
thing i didn't have an internet
connection in my house when i was a
a child that but i had a computer like i
would play doom and
and all sorts of and prince of persia
like was my favorite game of all time as
a kid
um but there was no internet so the way
that you got knowledge um when i was a
kid my dad's a scientist so i would read
a lot of isaac asimov books right
um both fiction and non-fiction but i
really liked the non-fiction books um
and so there was this encyclopedia set
called encyclopedia britannica
and they're like these red leather-bound
books with the gold foil
around that the pages and they look
really
like posh really fancy and as a kid
i remember um i wanted encyclopedia the
encyclopedia set so badly it was like
bucks it probably cost an obscene amount
of money
but i wanted it so badly and i would
just
hound my parents and be like mom dad
like
i don't want toys toys i want the
wikipedia set
and so um i got the encyclopedia set and
i spent
most of my childhood reading and
materials like a nerd um because i
loved knowledge like my dad would come
into my room two in the morning
and i'd be reading my encyclopedias in
bed with a flashlight and you'd be like
oh no like other kids would get grounded
for
making trouble i would get in trouble
for reading encyclopedias my parents
would be like you need to sleep
child and i was like oh knowledge um
so i think just being like a sponge and
always wanting to
to know things right like why does that
work that way how does that happen
what's the precedent here like why do we
do that that way i'm sure i was the most
infuriating and most annoying
child i had a lot of questions um but
that sort of persisted
and i think in a space like bitcoin
right that type of behavior is
rewarded so i'm glad that i'm in this
space where
like something that has historically
been perceived as a character flaw
is now a character's strength so
yeah i think no i think being driven by
driven by knowledge
is is like a it's a gift it's the most
amazing thing
um because you are so knowledgeable in
it and i i absolutely
enjoy every time um your your stints pop
up on my twitter
i really enjoy i learn so much from it
um
but it's also occurring yes also right
no it's not i don't believe it how is it
a curse
okay because like last night normal
people right
having a 7 a.m podcast would have gone
to bed at like
11 or midnight i stayed up because i was
i call them in
um i call them like black holes where i
will literally like
my mind will meld with the subject
matter i'm reading about or like my mind
will just like meld with my computer and
i looked up last night it was two in the
morning
and i was reading you know i was on a
random topic hunt like
i was in a deep black hole about the
history of ticker tapes um i love market
structure i love market history
so i was reading about like ticker tapes
and there's um this great book from the
30s called confessions
of the confessions from the ticker tape
or something
um so i was reading about ticker tapes
and good i was like oh i think it's
great it's 2 am i
need to go the to sleep no i think
it's great sometimes sometimes i do that
like i have i have an obsession with
space
um it just sounds the most ridiculous
thing but i'm just fascinated by all of
it by wormholes black holes
time travel so no no i'm the same i can
stay up until like 3 a.m
like do you have do not go websites like
for me wolf from alpha which is the math
website
is like i can't go there if i go there
that's like seven
hours minimum do not go website
wikipedia
do not go website like it can't because
i'll just start clicking
right wikipedia is the worst for people
like me who have like
severe ocd i don't know what i have but
i have something
um my parents i was so funny story i did
a puzzle with my parents recently
yeah and when i puzzle i get into the
same state like i get obsessed and i
just
i see a piece and i know exactly where
it goes and my parents are both sitting
there because i basically did the puzzle
by myself and they were like
yeah what's wrong with you like there's
something
really wrong with you that we didn't
figure out
when you were kid like you're not this
is not normal behavior i was like i i
know
no i think it's great i think it's
winning i think it's winning behavior if
anything that's what it is it's weird
no it is it is but okay so you mentioned
earlier that you think that right now
things are very much
retail driven um so we've definitely
seen that um
the most this i think with them we've
ever seen compared to any bull market
especially i know it's obviously not
crypto but with like
um you know amc gme and that kind of
attitude towards doge
um so why now like why would you say now
retail investors are particularly um i
don't
call it angry but particularly um
passionate and
ready to sort of take on um the system
they're active right retail's very
active and you know what's so
fun leia is like historically when um
so i remember like when i was a you know
teenager i got into trading
stocks for a very brief period of time
but stock trading has always been boring
like stocks are
so boring right you like buy a couple
shares with exxon it's where i used to
work
wait what's boring is it the lack of
volatility in comparison to crypto
it's it's not only the lack of
volatility it's the limited access that
retail has historically had
to more sophisticated um instruments
right
and so um historically right most people
their only interaction with investing
would be through their 401k or their ira
and typically what they're doing right
is they're going on whatever platform
they have and they're buying a target
date fund right like a target 2050
retirement date fund
and so those funds are are allocated
according to
um risk right so if you're going to
retire in year 2050
it's now your 2021 you can afford to
take a lot more risk because you have 29
years until you're going to retire
whereas if you have a target 2030 fund
like that's only nine years so it's
going to be much lower risk profile
so bigger portion of that portfolio is
going to be bonds so there is a
again nothing exists in isolation so
confluence of factors here
number one most important factor in my
view is technology
okay financial technology and fintechs
in particular
have made it easier for investors to
access markets
and the way this manifests itself in
crypto is in the 2017 and the
by the way also the reason crypto is way
more volatile and also is going to be
way more correlated to tech equities
in the coming years is this it used to
be that if i wanted to trade crypto in
i would have to get uh sign up for a
crypto exchange
figure out a way to get bitcoin right
and it was really only bitcoin that was
used as the primary funding mechanism
in 2017 i'd have to figure out a way to
get bitcoin i'd probably get it on
coinbase or kraken or something but
really mostly coinbase then i'll get my
bitcoin i would take that bitcoin i
would send it
to um what were the exchanges i'm like
kucoin
or okay one of these platforms and i
would trade crypto there and it was all
crypto to crypto
today if i want to trade crypto i don't
even have to leave the app
where i'm trading stocks i can trade
cryptocurrencies in my of robin hood i
can trade them inside of sofi
cash app you name them any number of
applications etoro right which like
congrats to yoni for for going public
um any any of these fintech platforms
like now crypto is just part of
the normal slate of options that you
have in
in the menu so in 2017
couldn't trade crypto easily really
difficult to move money in and out
now right i can trade my amc my game
stop my dogecoin
and my come rocket like all in the same
account which is
great and you forgot you forgot as well
how dare i um and i say that not to be
cheeky but technology really is the
primary driver of this changed behavior
number one number two let's talk so
that's like the mechanical reason why
so but markets are just a way for people
to express their sentiment right
so the tools now exist for retail
consumers to easily express their
sentiment which is why
yeah increase participation but what's
driving that sentiment
retail is tired of getting i do
think that investing is a new form of
entertainment
during the pandemic people looked at
volatility and tech equities and they
realized wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute there's this
whole thing going on over here that i
haven't been paying attention to
but while the government is busy
printing right the dollar into oblivion
um what am i gonna do one of the biggest
challenges and we wrote a great piece on
this as a corporate treasurer right i
identify with this as a former corporate
treasurer i should say
i identify with this rates are down
right so real interest rates are zero
i get paid nothing for loaning my money
to a financial institution
my market funds which were long
considered no risk or like very very low
risk investments
is cash equivalents yields zero
inflation right is 2.5
target but realistically it's probably
higher than that double if not treble
that depending on what
you know but we could talk about how
inflation measures are are whack
but um here you are you're sitting here
you're losing spending power every year
if you're not investing
and i think people are starting to wake
up to that reality the other big driver
is education right fintwit or financial
twitter
influencers or financial influencers
right there are
so many amazing people who are super
smart
super knowledgeable who are putting out
great content like look at you doing
this podcast
so the fact that people have access to
really high
quality research insights advice um
that's never existed before
it used to be that you had to be you
know person with a private banker or
person with a you know
a broker in order to get sound financial
advice and in order to get really high
quality
sell side research now is open to
everyone
right the model for information and
financial services
is democratizing information making it
widely accessible
the rise of financial twitter has been
really interesting to
to watch um and then the the last piece
is so you have sentiment right
so education changing macro market
conditions people are then expressing
that sentiment through these new
technology tools that we have
where it's really so much easier to
access these markets people can trade
options in an
app like the first time first time i
traded options in an app i was like
no this is crazy you can right
it's wild um so you have sentiment
sentiment gets expressed in the market
through this this new technology we have
these new capabilities
and then the last piece i think that's
really important is just the
gamification of
everything right my thesis has always
been like
anything and everything is a market
anything and everything is a financial
asset
because at the end of the day right
markets are just sentiment machines
which is why again
it's it's for me always so interesting
to go back to
sentiment as the driver sentiment
enables you know
sentiment is enabled by technology which
is why i spend a lot of time thinking
about market structure and how
changes in the market structure are
going to impact the way that people
express their sentiment and then that
expression of sentiment
obviously is going to lead to sort of
changes in in markets and prices
themselves
um and then the last piece i think
that's so interesting again gamification
of everything
everything is becoming a market we're
going to see all sorts of esoteric
markets emerging definitely one of the
themes we're building around
at coin shares is digitization of
everything
and then distribution evolving where
there's no longer an intermediary
right so again it used to be if i wanted
to construct a portfolio
i'd buy a portfolio constructed by
vanguard
or charles schwab or you know fidelity
whoever
my my service provider is and i buy
their you know
tech sector fund or i buy their you know
target date 2050 fund and be like okay
this is good
i'm going to make it and i think people
now are looking at this and they're like
not going to make it that's and yeah and
so people are taking much more ownership
um that has bad impacts right like
there's negative impacts and positive
impacts
but my view is any time that people are
incentivized and motivated to learn
and take accountability for their
financial well-being like that's
positive in my book
the fact that i went through like what
18 years of schooling
and i never learned how to balance a
checkbook i never really
learned how to construct a portfolio but
i like learned
the laws of thermodynamics and like you
know
how many how many molecules are in you
know a milliliter of
something you know it's wild i learned
all of these things but i didn't learn
the most
basic things i think one of the
fundamental things people need to know
so that they can take accountability and
responsibility
is how to manage their finances and what
worked in the past is not going to work
going forward because the world's not a
static place
a lot of people have this assumption
that like there are absolute maxims
there aren't right the universe is
constantly changing
entropy is real all things tend towards
chaos
we're going through a phase of
exceptionally high entropy right now
and again this is why knowledge is power
like you have to understand the
fundamentals of how things work
in order to survive in a wide variety of
market conditions
and what i what i worry about is you
know a bunch of people are about to to
retire they're counting on retirement
funds to be there
but the what worked in the past is not
going to work in the future
um and we're entering into a whole new
wild west and i think people who take
the time and the effort
and the courage like right it takes
courage to do this stuff
but the people who go down that path i
think will be
rewarded um you know we're in a world
where no one's going to save us
so we have to save ourselves i mean
that's why we're on bitcoin
yeah no i mean i i agree with everything
with everything that you said and
it is a completely different world i
remember even telling my dad when tesla
had put 1.5 billion into bitcoin um he
sort of he asked me when are you selling
and i was like you don't understand what
do you mean what am i selling this means
you hold even tighter
um yeah well what i always say is like i
when we get to where we're going
you won't need to celebrate excel right
exactly
yeah yeah of course because everybody's
gonna adopt it that's that's my goal
anyway but
you're totally right when you talk about
um you know the fintechs because
um in the uk we have revolut i'm not
sure if you have that um
in the states yet but in europe we have
revolu and actually today they just
announced that um
you can now have they will now host more
coins so it's not just like
bitcoin eth and xrp i think it was now
it's a whole load of other
coins um but yeah i mean you know in
2017 you didn't have things like tick
tock for example tick tock is huge at
driving the market which is absolutely
insane if you think about it
um yeah but tick-tock right but
tick-tock is just a medium right so the
medium is not the message
the message is the message right tik-tok
is just really
good at um spreading information tick
tock is really good
at feeding you content that you didn't
even know you wanted
so tick tock is really just really good
at understanding your sentiment and what
you like and keeping you on the platform
and then it just feeds you content but
the people creating content right
there's this huge shift
um influencers right if i like
when i was growing up influencer like
fit finance influencer was not a thing
um i didn't know that that was a thing
i've never had the time
my friends tease me and they call me if
influencer they're like what are you
gonna
you're off influencer right like yours
you're sponsored
yeah yeah your your podcast is supported
by companies in the fintech space
but i think this idea right um
here's what's really cool five years ago
let's go back five years ago right when
i first started crypto if i wanted to
learn about bitcoin like
crypto twitter wasn't really as big of a
thing as it is now
but a lot of my early bitcoin education
came from going to bitcoin talk
right like bitcoin talk read it that
that's where i was hanging out maybe a
little bit of fortune but like
let's kind of sweep that under the rug
but for that i think we just did tell
everyone
but um that that's where like these
conversations were happening
today right if i want to learn about a
variety of different topics like i have
different people that i follow in my
feed like i have macro people
lynn alden is my number one macro person
like she's
so brilliant and i love reading her
research so i have macro people that i
follow
semiconductors huge area of passion of
mine i have a bunch of semiconductor
influencers that i follow um fx right
and
em emerging markets so foreign exchange
fx em emerging markets
fx and em another area i'm really
interested in there's a couple of people
i follow
robin brooks is one of my favorites um
he writes a lot about em
particularly turkey and the emea region
so being from there like
really interested and learn a lot from
him but there are all of these amazing
people who are really incredible like
well well-credentialed
people some of them are also self-taught
and self-educated which i
i love most of them i'd say probably are
to be honest i think it's
in this kind of mix to be fair right
like a lot of people do
have like really really uh institutional
quote-unquote backgrounds like i have a
very
institutional background like i have
pieces of paper with my name on them
from institutions that supposedly like
mean something
but i also think what's really cool
about fintwit and
influencers and tick tock is like the
democratization
of um credentialing like institutions no
longer carry the weight that they did
it's about doing the work and that's why
i love crypto like crypto truly is a
meritocracy
if i would have stayed in the energy
industry if i was a good girl and worked
hard and was nice to my co-workers
and did everything that my corporate
overlords asked me to like maybe at the
age of 50 i would become
an executive and i would make it like
here i am
i'm in my mid 30s i work in crypto i'm
crazy i don't listen to anyone
i'm completely uncontrollable and
my company is publicly listed um and
you know it's in no other universe does
that happen
but the fact that people can do this the
fact that like
there are entrepreneurs out there who
are just crushing it and doing
incredible things and aren't
credentialed don't come from
institutions
i absolutely love that um and what
balaji is doing with his 1729 project
which is a massive global talent and
idea search i think is so
powerful and i want to see more of that
like
it's wild it's so cool i just
you never know where my ideas are going
to come from but they could come from
anywhere
it's awesome yeah i think i think it's i
think it's amazing you know i like i
i'm the first to say that university
isn't necessary for everyone i'm the
first to say that
um i mean i study journalism so i don't
have an actual technical
financial degree or anything like that
totally just
learning and going with the flow and
sort of figuring it all out
um but no i'm totally with you but
earlier you mentioned um
about how this is a very much uh an
entertainment
trading is now entertainment and which
might not be a good thing
but like that's inevitable it's enough
it doesn't
it's inevitable like fighting it is a
fool's error it's inevitable
and people are mad about it i see
comments where they're like tick tock
and memes will erode education like it's
inevitable
so like the trend is your friend you can
spend your energy fighting trends or you
can embrace none
exactly so the way i look at it is this
is very much entertainment driven and
that's totally fine as long as you're
aware of
it then you can just understand it like
you said once you know the trend it's
your friend
and then you can monetize and go with
that and do what you want to do trade
buy doge when it's down whatever
so this leads me onto a subject i really
want to talk to you about um which is
elon
musk because i know you have some views
on this um
don't turn your head i know you have
some really good views on this so i do
want to ask you about it
there's two parts okay okay no no let's
hear it let's hear it sorry
so there's two parts going on here
there's the doge
part of it and the and the manifestation
of meme coins
um and then we can get onto the bitcoin
mining council because i i know you have
stuff to say about that but
in terms of doge and meme coins and
things like that
do you think elon musk endorsing doge
because that's 100
what he's done um endorsing doge
is dangerous or bad or
is bad financial advice although nothing
is technically financial advice
a lot of questions okay let's just go
back to elon
here is my take on elon musk elon musk
is the kim kardashian of twitter
here's what i mean by that kim
kardashian is the queen of
instagram she's the queen of content one
of the most followed people
on that platform i think she has over
100 million followers like some crazy
amount
elon musk is the most followed person on
twitter i believe
70 million followers
so i think what what we're doing here
like we're confusing
cause and effect elon is not the cause
of anything
elon just happens to have a lot of
followers the most followers i think of
anyone on twitter
so he's a massive megaphone anything he
tweets about is gonna have
ten thousand times more reach he has
more followers than probably all of
fintwich combined
so the definition of an influencer yeah
yeah but he's like the
influencer and osmar this is a track
jacket thank you for noticing
i haven't worn my peachy track jacket in
a long time
um so i'm excited about it it's like
it's time
it's time for me to come out of my
hiding hole and like
be in the the
skin it's good to wax you know what it
was seven a.m
like i hadn't slept a lot because i was
doing weird last night it's fun
um but but elon right biggest influencer
on twitter so naturally
anything that he tweets about is gonna
get massive distribution and pick up
and so um what really happened with elon
and dogecoin
dosh was a thing before elon musk hopped
on the bandwagon
and elon musk i don't know what his
motivations are honestly i think he's a
billionaire he's bored he loves chaos
like i'm a creature of chaos so i know
i know a creature of chaos when i see
one and i'm like oh this man he likes
chaos
he's just making chaos like he's
with people he's having fun he's like
he just doesn't he doesn't care so
elon's not the cause but he is the
amplification right like he's the
massive megaphone and
anything that gets refracted through the
elon musk
sort of prism right is gonna be a thing
so when elon started talking about
dogecoin and he's been doing this for a
while
i think honestly he just thought it was
funny like magical internet money
sheba hilarious sorry like the whole
thing is just funny
it's also a perfect encapsulation of the
zeitgeist of the moment
right if we look at what's happening in
markets more broadly like we live in
clown world
yeah i say this all the time like we
live in clown world and it's
sad but also funny and what's the
quote it's like the most preposterous or
the most absurd outcome is the most
likely
right like we all kind of want to be
entertained we're also somewhat
nihilistic
i think like as a modern society so um
yeah so elon look he's
just a giant megaphone through which
stuff is is getting refracted
the issue we get into is i think when
elon started talking about bitcoin
first of all for someone who added 1.5
billion dollars of bitcoin to their
balance sheet the comments that he made
about bitcoin
appeared to be really ill-informed like
demonstrating fundamental
misunderstandings and misconceptions
about how bitcoin works
i think again for most people that would
be fine but if you're a technologist
running two publicly like two large one
publicly listed one not publicly listed
at very late stage
like companies you kind of
would think they would they would know
um some of these very basic things or do
a little bit of work but
before they started tweeting about it
but clearly that wasn't done
um and then with the the bitcoin mining
council stuff
um like look i get that the aspirations
of the bitcoin mining council
are pure
i think any time you start pandering to
narratives though then the narrative
starts to write the story
the issue i have with crypto generally
and
i'm guilty of this myself so this
criticism i'm also leveling at myself
the issue i have is we let other people
write stories about
us and here's the really interesting
thing and this is why history's so
important
mythology is part of how humans make
meaning of a very confusing confusing
universe right
we write stories and tell stories to try
to understand and contextualize what's
happening in a very complex world that's
very difficult for us to understand
so what's happening right now in the
crypto space
is we are letting other people tell
us stories about ourselves we are
letting other people from outside of our
industry
people like elon musk like yes elon musk
might be super smart yes he might be
super successful yes he might be really
interesting
but why the are we letting some
random person
tell us what our industry is about
you are you become like what you say you
are the stories you tell yourself about
yourself are the most
powerful and up stories this is
why a lot of people are in in
therapy like this is why a lot of people
need
help because they've been told these
stories all of their lives
and the stories the mythology that
you're taught becomes reality
so the issue i have with the crypto
community right now like who the
cares what elon
said literally who cares he is one
of eight billion people who live on this
planet and one who's literally been in
bitcoin for like six months
and we're gonna let this person write
the story
no you're doing it wrong elon is the
megaphone that we use
once we have the story we want but it's
up to us like take some personal
responsibility tell the story that needs
to be told
and again this is why i love like the
the vision of bitcoin this is why i love
what alex got seen at the human rights
foundation is doing with rewriting the
story around bitcoin
this is why i love there are a couple of
great documentaries coming out around
bitcoin in different parts of the
bitcoin ecosystem
we need to win hearts and minds we need
to write our own history we need to
write our own stories
like mythology is the most important
thing
storytelling is how we transmit
narratives messages right the memes
are the message elon has captured this
the crypto community
is kind of like fumbling over its feet
we need to start taking control of the
narrative
i think we're starting to learn but
again this is one of the challenges
of bitcoin right we don't have a
marketing department
there's no central entity no one speaks
for bitcoin
bitcoin has no spokespeople no masters
but what makes me sad is when i see
bitcoiners simping
for people who like have literally done
xero for the bitcoin community
um what we need to do is sim for people
in our community
who are actually driving the industry
forward and there are a ton of great
people in the bitcoin space who just
show up every day and have shown up
every day for the last 10 years
and just do the work like let's simp for
some bitcoin core devs
instead of simping for a board
billionaire who's looking
to keep himself in in the news and again
that's not a dis on elon like elon's
great but i think we need to again just
be more cognizant
of how we create narratives to take
ownership of the narrative
and to write the mythology of bitcoin
like we need we need we need bitcoin
historians we need
that's why historians used to be like
very revered in ancient cultures because
people realized
reality facts don't really matter it's
the story
right what gets passed down throughout
history is the story
and that's how memes perpetuate and
again elon tiktok all of these things
they're just megaphones through which we
amplify the message but the message
itself we have to take ownership of
sorry i get i get so right on this it's
whack i'm just like why are we
why are we doing this we know how to do
this
yeah i think that he has you know he's
been in bitcoin for five minutes he's
annoyed a lot of people um and for me i
just can't help but think and feel
that it's not entirely um he just didn't
know
and you know when he flip-flopped on
energy for me i think there's more to it
a lot of people say you know maybe he's
bored that's why he's pumping doge
but and maybe i'm giving him too much
credit maybe i am
but whatever i for me there's something
more to it
um and i'm intrigued to see what happens
i get the whole you know
he's hurting he's hurting bitcoin which
you know he is
given his following and how he's just
feeding into the fudd
yeah let me ask you a question though
yeah go for it the fact that one person
who has been a bitcoin as you said for
five minutes
can damage the market sentiment
is that not concerning of course it is
no it's absolutely concerning it's
where it's supposed to be a
decentralized ecosystem so
the fact that one person can move a
market is concerning what i'm saying is
i think
he's got something else but but i think
again we're giving this person too much
power like this person doesn't have this
power
actually like elon tweeting about
bitcoin again not the effect
sorry not the cause he's the effect
right he came
after leverage getting unwound that's a
cause
right institutional sentiment flipping
bearish on macro in general
that's a cause tax day selling that's a
cause
not elon musk that's an effect
right and so people are not
understanding the basic dynamics of
cause
and effect cause other
other factors some endogenous to the
bitcoin ecosystem itself some exogenous
right
cause affect elon tweeting about it
he just has the most followers of anyone
on the bird website i.e twitter
which is why people prescribe cause to
him
but i think again what's so crazy to me
is like we give our power away
so easily the power is in storytelling
like every day i wake up leah
and i'm like today we are gonna do this
and if i just keep telling myself like
seven years ago when i
left a well-paying career to get into
bitcoin i was like
this is going to be great you're going
to make it like you got this and i would
tell myself these stories i was like
it's going to be great like you have to
get coin crashed you know 70
i was like this is great i love it here
but look
you have to believe in the power of
storytelling
and you have to tell better stories i'm
like let's
let's let's just stop so i'm really
hopeful
um that we can get over the simpling but
honestly what i'm seeing is is not
encouraging
and this is the flip side right this is
the flip side of the mummification of
finance
so on the topic of storytelling because
i'm totally with you i think
it is so important especially just on a
personal level like you said
seven years ago you were like it's gonna
be great um it's so important it's
something i do myself
all the time um but story this market is
still such an immature market and it's
largely
narrative driven and there's been a lot
of interesting narratives coming out of
china and many other exciting places so
you said that you've been here for about
seven seven years when you when you left
your your nice comfy cushy job
so fudd doesn't go away it just
keeps coming back you know when i was
doing um i was really trying to get my
head wrapped around the whole energy
thing
so i started watching um some andreas
videos
from back in like 2016 17 and it's the
same conversation so
given you've been here for such a while
why is this still a thing like why is
this
conversation still happening and do you
think we'll get to a point
whereby we finally don't even need to
discuss this anymore
like is bitcoin a scam i feel like we've
kind of shot that one
no but there look there will always be
people who believe um bitcoin is a scam
oh steven just called me insane thank
you stephen i
i am insane and if you don't believe in
the power of storytelling
examine your own beliefs about the world
and see how many of them are facts and
how many of them are artistic
reinterpretations
uh of history like the history you've
been taught in school
is basically storytelling it's not based
on fact but
cute i'm totally with you i just want to
say no i'm totally with you i think your
reality is constructed by stories that
other people tell you like if you don't
realize that then like you need to
re-examine your conception of your
perception of reality like we do live in
a matrix the matrix is
people manipulating your emotions right
um so again
okay but but moving on to to sort of
this this fudd
thing as you said we've been fighting
fud um
lol objective facts the only objective
facts are the laws of thermodynamics but
cute um i can't believe
i can't believe you're going ahead and
like one-on-one with the comments right
now
i realize malcolm's going one-on-one
with the comments leah i love comments
like i'm the person who goes like
deep i go balls deep in the comments
section i'm like comment once
and i'm like um
issues okay um sorry so with a fud right
yes
here's the issue um and here's why i
think the fud keeps coming back it's not
about
facts for people who uh perpetuate fud
it's not about facts
there are still people out there who
believe that if they try hard enough
like
bitcoin will get get killed there are
people out there who believe that
bitcoin will shut down
like bitcoin was shut down by the
government and the reason the fud
comes up repeatedly is because there are
people out there
who don't live in the same reality we do
so if we go back seven years right in 20
early 2015 it was really only bitcoin
like the ethereum network hadn't
launched yet
yet yes there had been a wave of icos on
on bitcoin and they are like scam coins
and coins
but it was really only bitcoin at the
core of this community
and at that point in time a lot of
people that i would talk to
um would would say like you know oh
bitcoin it's a scam it's crazy the
overall market cap of bitcoin was what
like maybe
500 million 750 million is like very
small market
um and so back then right
the reality that we live in now the
beliefs people had around bitcoin didn't
exist
over the last seven years right a bunch
of people on the internet
have worked together to meme and like
make the and storytell and build and put
this whole new reality into perspective
and help other people
shift their mindset um and shift their
mental models to accept bitcoin
so now the army of bitcoiners i like to
call it has gone from like maybe
300 people you could put all of us in a
room like seven years ago there's
not that many people now it's a huge
community it's global
um and there are millions of people who
believe in in bitcoin
and so i think there's still people out
there who believe in fundamentally
different reality and just cannot accept
a reality in which bitcoin exists
which is why the fud will continue to
persist the fund is always some
variation of the following
energy use fud um uh china
fud right um cia like
intel fud um uh crime
terrorism um etc like
the fun is the same stuff it just keeps
coming up every cycle and there's
different people pushing it
but i also think the other challenge is
because um
because we haven't um in the bitcoin
ecosystem right like the narratives just
repeat themselves every cycle
because we haven't really done a great
job coming up with new narratives
what's really interesting to me leia is
i try making new narratives sometimes
and i'll start saying like
for example when the esg stuff came up i
was like it's not just about the e it's
also about the s and the g
and now i hear other people saying that
look at that
about the ability to create new
narratives but i think again
um you know that the fud is just part of
change being really hard for human
beings
the fact that there's this alternate
monetary reality and it's not a toy
right people think bitcoin is not real
i'm like there's a trillion dollars of
economic value on an open source
protocol
um that's that's real this is real
for tens of millions if not hundreds of
millions of people around the world
and again what i want to go back to is
history and this is why education like
educating yourself and learning is so
important
the most um sort of tumultuous turbulent
period of history um in
in recent history is um the creation of
the printing press
right and martin luther and the
protestant movement right
and um and the age of westphalia if we
think about the impact
that the printing press had on the
development of human society
and the impact the internet has had on
the development of human society
any time we see these massive shifts
where people's
fundamental beliefs around the world
start to change
those are periods of great change and
great upheaval and i believe we're going
through one right now
where we're seeing the end of one system
or one way of being
where nation states are the most
powerful entities in our world and
define that the landscape in which we
operate to a world in which nation
states are no longer going to be the
dominant superpowers
and i think what was so scary to people
about libra is
facebook only over half of
the um of half of the people in the
world right
half of the population of this planet
uses facebook
on a daily basis
facebook is way more powerful than any
nation state of course way more powerful
google
is more powerful than any nation state
and what's crazy to people and i think
what scares the out of people when
it comes to bitcoin
is bitcoin has proved like historically
movements social movements in particular
and i believe bitcoin is a social
movement in many ways
but it's the first social movement with
money right
and that's really scary because it
threatens power
um and i believe in the future nation
states will no longer be the only
players on the geopolitical stage
it will be nation states but it will
also be
communities and metaverses right like
there are whole groups of people who are
hanging out online who believe in a
totally different reality than you and i
do
and by the way q anon in the us was
simply an expression of that
right it was a group of people believing
in a very different reality
i i don't prescribe to that reality but
the fact that there are a group of
people who
who do and who believe it so much is
absolutely wonderful
yeah and what we're starting to see is
like the fragmentation of our world into
these different sort of
narrative like reality shards where
people
occupy these different realities these
different mental spaces
and again this is why like facts yes i
believe in facts i believe in
information
but the narrative the stories
this is what's moving people to action
and i think this
is why learning how to communicate
effectively such an important skill to
have
because if you're not good at
communicating your ideas if you can't
find a way to get them to the market
like
then your ideas aren't useful um yeah
or they're not sorry that's not it's not
not useful it's um it's very difficult
for people to act on those ideas
so again like i could sit here in my
little office you know
and have the best ideas in the world but
if nobody's listening to them
if if nobody's sharing them if nobody's
building on them if they're not you know
getting worked into the narrative into
this like narrative tapestry that gets
woven every day on the internet
then those those ideas aren't being
utilized
and so i think a lot of times people
forget like creation of content and
creation of knowledge is one thing
distribution and dissemination of
knowledge and content is another really
important skill set
and in this post-truth internet age
that is a really important muscle for us
to learn to build
and then the last thing i'll add is like
i get attacked every single day on the
internet and people are always like how
do you do it and i'm like
you just have to put on your teflon coat
like you have to recognize that in order
to do
things that are are interesting and in
order to see things before they become
trends or my job as an investor is to do
that
you're going to have to be willing to
take risks and go against the narrative
in order to create new narratives
um and we saw this with kovid right like
the whole covid was it created in the
lab or not again
i have no horse in this race i actually
like like whatever it's kind of
don't care about that not my world but a
bunch of people were canceled last year
for saying that
now it's starting to be the consensus
opinion so
i think again like you have to build
your own
resilience you have to remove this
desire to constantly be liked or to be
in consensus
but our job is humans right literally
all we are is meaning making machines
we're taking in information from a bunch
of different inputs
we're trying to contextualize that
information based on our own experiences
our own knowledge
and what's going on around us and then
to create a new narrative
or to set our perception of what reality
is and what's possible in this version
of reality
and i think sometimes you have to
suspend disbelief i did that seven years
ago and i got in
into bitcoin um and again i think we're
at a stage where we have to ourselves
suspend disbelief like i think bitcoin
will do amazing things in this world
that none of us ever expected myself
included
but in order for that to be possible we
have to believe it
and i worry i worry about all of you
sometimes like let's be more resilient
people are
so fragile let's be resilient like we
really really are very resilient as
humans
um and so you know you have to be
willing to change your mind which in and
of itself is a really difficult skill
but
i do think that um over the next 10 to
20 years
the profound changes that will be
inspired by
um bitcoin will blow people away
oh yeah i'm so excited i know i love it
no i love i think i think your your
passion as well is so admirable and i
think in terms of being resilient
that passion is really necessary but
just one really
i don't know obviously keep you too long
i know you have a flight to catch today
um but one last topic i just quickly
want to ask you about um i guess it kind
of
comes off the back of that where is it
going then because like
we have the development of cbdc's you
know europa developing that china
developing that i think it was
ray dalio that said china's digital
currency will
totally outperform um a digital dollar
and they co-exist so
he said that he said sorry can we talk
about ray dalio for a moment sorry
okay it's okay ray dalio literally said
um
a digital remember right like the the
chinese cbdc will um
will be like more competitive than
bitcoin i'm like i'm sorry where the
is the volatility like clearly
you've never traded
anything ray ray like i love ray dalio i
he's great um but like
where where's the volatility no i don't
think i'm a trader
i started my career trading that's never
left me like i see volatility and normal
people are like oh my god my portfolio's
down 40
and i'm like oh like it is i love it
i'm an animal it's disgusting no i think
it's great it's brilliant but cbdc's you
know
can they coexist with bitcoin do you
think um
they are created to try and compete with
bitcoin
will it kind of confuse the average
person that
thinks this is a cryptocurrency okay
so again if we go back to so first of
all
great question but i think people who
ask that question right are forgetting
one fundamental thing
so i'm gonna get philosophical for a
moment um
no this is going to this so so leia if i
ask you like
who are you tell me about you leia how
do you describe yourself
oh god okay um i would say that i'm
that's that's hard
um yourself um
how do you describe myself i'd say i'm
like a little
nuts as well um i'd say like positive
um excitable um i believe in creating a
beautiful life i believe in freedom
i believe in happiness where are you
from london
okay and um uh what do you do
i do bitcoin stuff okay so so what i
think's really interesting about
so i thought you would describe yourself
like a lot of times when you ask people
like oh who are you
right they'll say my name is x i don't
do that i do i do y
for a living they're like i work in
finance i don't know
and i'm from london right
the world like that you don't that's why
it was hard i was like trying to make a
point but then like
of course you don't because you're a
bitcoiner um but most people when you
talk to them the way they define their
self
is by their passport their religious
identity
right identity groupings um
so what's interesting is like
historically we defined ourselves on the
basis of physical jurisdiction
right these arbitrary lines that are
drawn on a map
right over which wars are fought define
who we believe we are as humans and
that's the world we've operated in for
the longest
time it defines the physical
jurisdiction we live in defines what we
can or can't do with our money the
markets we can or can't participate in
the knowledge we have and the knowledge
that we're indoctrinated in our
worldview
and the mythology were taught as
children right like
i could live a thousand miles away from
from new york and i would have a
radically different interpretation of
world history
not because the facts are different but
because the mythology is different and
the way we're taught is different
so physical jurisdiction for the last
forever right throughout all of human
history physical jurisdiction
has defined how we identify ourselves we
no longer live
in that world we live in a world where i
no longer and i'm obliged to be a
us person i can be whoever i want
and bitcoin at its core to me has always
represented choice
for the first time i have choice
i have the ability to choose for myself
what monetary system i want to belong to
what philosophical system i want to
belong to
etc and so what to me is really amazing
is we live in this new era where
physical jurisdiction no longer defines
who we are what we believe what we have
access to what we can do
and so this is the most important thing
people
have choice i no longer have to
i no longer have to be stuck right with
the dollar i could
choose and i have chosen to put the
majority of my net worth into bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies
people all around the world are choosing
choosing right operative word choosing
to do this we get to decide
for the first time for ourselves what
system we want to be a part of what
values we want to enforce
what stories we want to give power to
and that is so
incredibly incredibly incredibly
powerful here's the thing that's so
interesting
if bitcoin were a nation state it would
be one of the largest economies in the
world it would be one of the largest
populations in the world right
hundreds of millions of bitcoiners
trillions of dollars of economic value
moving on the bitcoin network every day
separate yeah and michael you stole the
words out of my mouth right like
separation of religious
religion and state that's what martin
luther was all about and that was
perpetuated right again technology
played a critical role
in speeding and accelerating that change
through the advent of the printing press
now right the next step is separation of
money and state
and by the way it's not just going to be
um nation states it's meta verses
it's it's digital communities where
people exist online like
this is why i read a lot of sci-fi
sci-fi feels prescient
because it's authors storytellers right
storytellers operative word
trying to articulate what the future
could look like based on the technology
and sort of the research that exists
today
and so this is again what's so exciting
to me is like if you think about
what bitcoin is at its core yes
technology is a huge component of it
it's also philosophy
but bitcoin at its core in my view is a
social movement
we have to yeah and osmar are totally
wild we need to suspend our disbelief
like
believe in the impossible now the
impossible can't defy the laws of the
universe which is why
i studied math and university it's like
math
math defines truth in our universe and
like math defines the possible
because the rules of thermodynamics have
not yet been violated right like we
don't have a perpetual emotion machine
yet
um but we have this
amazing creative space in which to build
and to build new narratives and new
realities and
new constructs of reality and like
people just really really really are
not able to tap into that energy that's
all i'm trying to do leia like i'm
trying to create a lot of positive
energy
and give people the the permission or
like the hold space for people so that
they can suspend their own disbelief and
see the world through different
perspective and recognize like
the only limitation to how we live our
lives
it's obviously there are a lot of
constraints and i'm not minimizing those
but it all starts with your mind right
like your mind is the most powerful
force in this universe
and we now have tools to change people's
minds like helping people make money
right bitcoin is has a great adoption of
flywheel because greed is the ultimate
adoption mechanism and i'm not saying
that in a critical way but like
if you make people's money they will be
happy so that's really the flywheel um
that gets bitcoin going
and as people go down the proverbial
rabbit hole right they find these layers
and layers
where they find really deep meaning and
really deep understanding
in all of these different fields from
mathematics to cryptography to
philosophy
like economics there's all of these
layers and layers as you start peeling
them back
and so there's a little bit of something
for everyone um in bitcoin
again sorry now i'm something for
bitcoin i'm like
i love you it's totally okay to sin for
bitcoin but no
i love it i think everything at the end
of the day is definitely philosophical
everything goes back to
to everything that you are saying and i
think in this this is why i get really
frustrated with the kind of the world
that we live in is because everybody's
so easy to complain
everybody's so miserable all the time
and i think we actually live in the most
privileged era
and it all comes down to technology
technology has of course its
disadvantages but it has its advantages
and totally i was talking about this on
twitter yesterday that
um you know we are now we are no longer
now confined to where
we were brought up or where we come from
um you know i
i'm from england and england it has
plenty of opportunities but it doesn't
have what america has nothing quite has
what america has
and i work with americans i only work
with americans so
my my career and the opportunities that
i have in life
are um are made better because i now
have access
to another country and um
you know you see this in developing
nations and obviously we don't have time
to get into defying stuff right now
but um you know yeah if i can just add
to your story right
i think the other pieces like you were
brought up
in in um england right and so you were
raised in a very specific way you were
told a very specific version of history
and i think the internet right in the
democratization of information
means that you now get the opportunity
to construct your own version of history
and to construct your own mythology
and to assemble your own stories by
incorporating all this different
information um i think that's so
cool like think about how much your view
on things has changed since you started
working in bitcoin
i mean just on that on that point um i
again we don't get into it because it's
another rabbit hole but um i'm would
never regard myself as a feminist
and um i you'd think where i come from
that i would
um but when you watch people like jordan
peterson who's over
on the other side of the world to me i
now have access to that information it's
completely changed my world view
you know since bitcoin i have an even
stronger
hostility towards um state control
and you know given history and
everything that's happened a kind of a
feeling and uh and like a fear you could
say
that the people that my friends don't
have and that's because um
you know i've joined this wild
cult and on that note i think uh peas on
frillo in the comments like some did up
the best construct your own mythology
yes i think um believe in the power of
mythos
and again for the fellow nerds out there
um
if you read about mythology and the role
that mythos or storytelling has played
throughout human history
i think you'll begin to appreciate the
power of of
of words of thoughts and their ability
to influence and inspire and move and
change the world in the trajectory of
the world
like ideas are the most powerful thing
um we now have more mediums than ever to
disseminate those ideas and that was
really what the internet and social
media were all about
and then bitcoin takes that a step
further by attaching monetary value to
ideas
um it's really wild it's really exciting
um we could talk about that we could
talk about
asia um yeah but like it's fun
it's like ah how is this the reality we
live in it's amazing
no it is amazing um but i feel like i
could talk to you about this for ages i
wish i was going to be in miami but the
borders are closed to the uk
unfortunately i'm coming to the uk
okay june i believe late june
um grab a drink yes let's and we can
talk all about
um mythology meet those because you're
telling you're doing mythos right right
here right like your show your podcast
is a way of creating a new shared mythos
you bring in different guests and
that again such a powerful such an
important thing to do but also puts you
like at the very center of narrative
construction which i think is a really
powerful tool
but i want to thank you so much your
energy is so contagious everybody in the
comments um can feel your energy
i think it's all about positivity and
it's so refreshing because this day and
age everybody's complaining
um there's so much um toxicity and
tribalism within the community so
it's such a pleasure just to be able to
have a conversation with somebody and so
thank you so
much um honestly so refreshing and yeah
absolutely let me know when you're i'm
in london and we'll grab that drink i'm
excited um it might have to be herbal
tea
after miami i feel like i will be in
like a
month-long recovery uh thanks so much
for having me leah i know we've been
meaning to do this for a long long time
um so i really appreciate you having me
on
i want to say thanks to everyone in the
comments for being so engaged i love the
troll box i love the comments um
if anyone wants to follow up directly on
anything i said my dms are open
i'm at melt underscore dem um or if you
just want to engage in the twitter
thread
um always you know love hearing from
people uh
feedback things to read different
perspectives
you know i think um the most important
thing is
to to challenge yourself with
perspectives that don't always sit
comfortably with you and just to like
sit with them and be okay being in
discomfort um
so that's that's fun uh always looking
for people to push me
push my thinking because that's how we
how we grow and evolve um
so thank you to everyone thanks to you
for for this opportunity
and don't be so bearish life is good
everyone bitcoin is
is good everything is happening and
let's write better stories like mythos
just if i
one take away meet those how do we
construct mythology
think about it talk about it um and then
get to work
with stories to write there you go so
we're only gonna be telling
bullish stories that's it um but yeah
absolutely melton said thank you guys so
much for watching
and of course we'll be back around the
same time next week
bye bye bye